[inaudible]
Lego is the biggest toy manufacturer on
the planets,
but nonetheless,
they aren't even on the stock markets.
Are there industry bm offs like Hasbro
and Mattel are listed on the Nasdaq
exchange,
but lego with bigger sales have presence
in most of the world's hands.
One of the most valued brands keeps its
status as a family business
and as we will see later,
this is one of the secrets to their
success,
but not only vast,
unlike a competitor's legging is the
best 20 manufacturer when it comes to
surviving crises.
So now you're wondering,
well,
what Christ is exactly am I talking
about?
Well,
of course that would be the toy crisis.
Do you remember when you were a kid and
maybe you wrote a list of things of what
you wanted for Christmas,
maybe you send it to Santa Claus or
someone else,
depending on where you're from.
Well,
what did you ask for for Christmas?
I'm sure many of you wanted things like
the playmobile pirate ship,
a house for your Barbie doll,
or perhaps those power rangers action
figures that changed their heads when
you pressed the button.
But today kids have changed their tastes
dramatically.
Most of the things they want for
Christmas these days.
Video Games and I don't think anybody
will be surprised if I say that the
video game industry is absolutely on
fire these days.
Titles like call of duty and battlefield
have a bigger budget than most Hollywood
productions.
However,
the toy industry,
well that's going the other way and this
explains news like this.
R US filed for bankruptcy,
but we'll keep stores open.
Yes,
Steve,
you at the toy industry is set only in
dire straits.
Let's,
there is an exception to this rule and
as you might imagine that exception is
Lego.
Two years ago they beat their own sales
records and they've been kicking us for
the whole last decade,
Christmas after Christmas.
The question is how is Lego surviving
the video game industry?
Is Lego as good as it seems or are we
maybe missing some details here?
Well,
today we are going to answer all of
these questions,
but before we do as usual,
that's taken a look back at the history
family
business that go.
He started out in a very small carpentry
workshop in a village called billings in
the middle of dinner.
Mark,
by that time,
there were already some big 20 companies
like Parker and the creators of
blockbusters and like monopoly or the
Ouija board.
During this time Mr Christine's and was
manufacturing all kinds of wood and
products.
But in 1932 he realized that
specialization is the key to success
with the health of his eight employees.
He started manufacturing toys and only
toys.
Soon his product stood out for their
quality.
In fact,
we could summarize it cause work
philosophy with one
quite need.
The
best is good enough.
Or Kirk Kristiansen,
founder of Lego,
but the turning point for Lego came
world war team.
One day a British salesman appeared in
this carpenter's workshop with a game
changing product and this was of course
plastic.
This brand new material and our
factories to create things in a cheap,
precise and industrial way time.
The new workshop manager was Mr
Christine's son,
son,
a man named gottfried.
He immediately realized the enormous
potential of this new material and some
years later and Lego licensed and now
famous block assembly system thus ends
with that.
The most successful toy of all time was
born.
Yeah,
controls that Lego are so intense that
even the blocks that are sold today in
2017 can be assembled with the ones that
were sold by manufacturers back in 1958
and the same applies to their corporate
philosophy.
If there is a characteristic of the
Christians and the family,
it's the they when that shooting,
here's an example before they started to
produce thesis in Green,
these fans more than 10 years conducting
studies and discussions of the companies
in the industry had no problem taking
out loans to buy new factories and come
up with new product lines,
but Lego was one of a kind.
They always tried to finance their
expansion with their own profits and
this explains why they had slower but
more solid growth.
Despite all of this,
during the 70s and eighties Lego was on
fire and their product is covered every
stage of a child's development.
This morning,
a kid as well.
They had deep play blocks with vivid
colors and bigger blocks.
After that,
between five and 15 years old,
you had the classic Lego pieces.
I finally,
for the teenagers,
he wanted to improve their engineering
skills.
There was Lego technic,
and let's be honest here,
has anyone not played with any of those
products
as if this was
not enough and they go had its own theme
park,
the famous Lego lands,
these weren't another moneymaking
machine.
Hold on a minute because in the nineties
things they went a little sour graphic
crisis.
The 1960s on known as the baby boom
couples in Europe and America had lots
and lots of babies and this meant the
during the seventies and eighties there
were enough kids to sustain the 20
manufacturing industry.
Nonetheless,
the 90s they were a totally different
animal.
All of a sudden families have less kid
and as you can imagine,
this was a bad thing for a company like
Lego.
Every year they sold less than the
previous one and no matter how many fun
parks they opened in the United States,
profits kept getting lower and lower.
These were bad times for Lego.
I'm a Christian
family,
which makes toy plastic building blocks,
expects to report a loss in 1998 it's
the first since the 1930s during these
years,
the CEO is the founder's Godson,
Cagelles Christianson.
He was 57 years old and he had been
leading the company for nine years.
He saw how day off today his family
business was getting towards bankruptcy.
In that moment,
he took one of the bravest and wisest
decisions and can take.
He stepped aside and let someone younger
take charge.
Y'All didn't,
couldn't stop with just 36 when he took
Lego's wheel.
Not only that,
he was the first CEO that came from
outside of the Christian Center family.
Nonetheless,
this transition,
he was a friend.
Anyone performer in the new CEO worked
alongside each other for years.
Okay,
good.
[inaudible] would advise and Jorgen with
the site and this new strategy.
It was based on two pillars.
Specialization as marketing.
On the one hand,
they go,
got rid of everything that didn't
contribute to what they did best.
Manufacturing plastic blocks.
The rest was totally extensible.
They went from 7,000 workers to a little
more than 3000 and Jorgen completely
restructured the company.
Up until then,
the lego video games were created by a
subsidiary called Lego interactive.
You're getting sold that fat men started
charging royalties to anyone who wanted
to produce lego inspired video games,
and the same is happening in other areas
of business.
Troubled Lego sells theme park.
The other pillar was marketing.
You're going to realize that his plastic
blocks were wonderful,
but they didn't really meet customers'
needs.
Of course,
teachers and experts agreed that Lego
was a really educational toy.
It all kids to be creative and
systematic.
Yeah.
Even rival companies recognize that Lego
blocks were of a higher quality,
but you guys about the opinion of a
pedagogue or a rival company,
you see when you have a toy
manufacturing company,
your consumers of the children,
so maybe you remember how it was when
you were a child.
What did you do when you played with
toys?
Made up stories.
Of course,
when it comes to the Lego blocks making
stories,
it isn't the first step.
First you have to put all the pieces
together so you can have the helicopter,
you can have with the police,
Scott,
you can have with the police station.
But once you have that,
you just want to play.
You want to make your own movie.
But the hero against the bad guy,
all of that good stuff.
This is how lego realized that children
needed characters,
scenarios and stories.
You see the old lego products,
there was something like this.
So yeah,
we're a steam train,
a pirate ship,
a castle,
a city.
Not exactly at the most thrilling things
ever.
But after 2000 lego products went to the
next level
lever
see an underwater city about to be
destroyed by a giant octopus.
So now here is the big question.
Do you think is more exciting?
A steam train or a giant optimists?
Well,
with this principal is how a new series
was born from the Atlantis series to the
now legendary bionicle.
All of a sudden lego stopped selling
plastic building blocks and started
selling story
stories.
Good enough.
And it's complex enough to inspire toys
but also even video games and even
movies.
That new product strategy was based on
three key questions.
What your getting called the three
moments of truth and a game one.
What it's advertised.
Does it make a child say,
I want this too.
Once he opens the box,
does it make them go,
I want more of,
yes,
one month later,
does he come back to the toy,
rebuild it and still play with it or
does he put it on the shelf and forget
about it,
but also any of that,
if kids like stories,
why don't make toys about their favorite
movies?
This is how lego partnered with Lucas
films to launch a collection based on
Star Wars Lego of course the same.
When's the Batman Lord of the rings and
even Harry Potter?
Virtually there is no movie the kids
enjoy that has no lego licensed products
and you can believe me,
these things are at a blockbuster.
There are hundreds of different makers
of action figures and dolls whose
corporate logos.
Children are increasingly in different
to Lego boasts,
an estimated 85% share of the building
block market.
It's like,
do you remember when I said Lego had
sold all its subsidiary companies that
didn't relate to manufacturing of
plastic pieces?
Well,
that was true,
but now they make a fortune with the
royalties they charge to all of those.
He made video games and movies about
Lego and believe me,
this has become an absolute money making
machine.
The lego movie premiered last Friday and
made $69 million in its opening weekend,
making it the largest debut of the year
so
far.
This explains why while other toy
companies are struggling to win the
battle against video games,
Lego is making record sales in all
markets,
including the USA.
Big Opportunity here is Asia.
This is a brand new untapped market
ready to be opened.
Companies like mattel or Hasbro are
already compensating for their losses
and America and Europe with sales in
China,
like for Lego.
This is a whole new challenge.
This is why they're making changes at
the company.
Again,
we aren't talking about a big challenge
here in the last 15 years.
Like it was multiplied best sales by
five and they went from having 3000
workers to more than 19,000 nonetheless,
you know from this video that
Christine's in his philosophy is not
about taking many risks,
but in the last two years sales have
declined to this or this and this.
Now they want to conquer China as they
want to have their accounting books
healthier than ever.
And this explains policies like this one
lego predict growth in its China
business but sheds 1400 jobs after a
sales slump.
Okay,
so now that you know the story of Lego,
the question really becomes,
do you think lego can conquer the
Chinese markets or do you think they're
going to lose the battle?
They're against video games?
Well,
please leave your answer in the comment
section below.
We love hearing from you.
So just before we finish the video
today,
just send me,
wish you all a very merry Christmas.
We only sell to this channel in the
middle of January this year.
And already we've got more than 250,000
subscribers from all over the world.
So again,
I'd like to thank you for your support,
your messages,
your comments,
they all make visual politic what it is.
So thank you all again.
I also want to thank for people who have
collaborated with this channel during
its first year.
We got to reconsider media guys,
of course,
the China uncensored team and all the
individuals.
He's helps us with our research.
All of you made this possible,
so from everyone here at visual politic,
thank you for your support and it's
happy holidays that sad.
Do you don't forget to visit our friends
at the weekends in immediate podcasts,
they provide the vocals in this episode,
that one,
not mine.
And also if you wants to learn more
about another successful company in this
video we tell you the story of Zuora and
the inditex group.
Click to watch that one and to do not
forget to visit our
friends@thereconsidermedia.com podcast.
They provided the vocals in this episode
that are not mine and was always,
remember that we published brand new
videos every week.
So do hit that subscribe button so you
don't miss a post.
And if you liked this video,
please do give it a thumbs up.
And as always,
I'll see you next time.
And if you want to learn more about
politics and hear more of my lovely
voice,
don't forget to check out the reconsider
podcast@reconsidermedia.com reconsider
as a podcast that challenges you to
reconsider your views by providing
context.
But we don't do the thinking.